hello everyone
I'm takudo hidoka the director of EXO
primal
I'm excited to share the latest EXO
Primal news with you all but first let's
check out this video
hello
my name is
basically the IP is Godfather
responsible for the entire exosuit
project you know anchor Division I
assume
EXO suits were developed right here
we need access to the Past
back in 2040. intact
access codes to override Leviathan
you set it down the whole thing
the fuel of the future all this time
Heisel is a side effect of time travel
they
out of dead dinosaurs
[Music]
we know why dinosaurs bleed blood
unrefined blows all in the blood
I mean look at this it's a walking glove
promise you this we'll find a way out of
here
all anchor project files have exterior
numbers look for anything starting with
one eight one that's the project code
for the bias its core
okay duck
I didn't get your name
the hammer hits
well done you fought desperately and
survived the perfect Exo Suit
development project is nearing fruition
activating Massacre module summoning Neo
T-Rex form
this is all helping to make a better exo
suit
foreign
laughs
what did you think
that was a lot of new info
before we dive in I'd like to give a
huge thanks to all the players who
participated in the open beta test back
in March
we were extremely pleased to have so
many participants plus you gave us a lot
of invaluable feedback
we can't thank you enough
while only portions of the dyno survival
content were made available for the open
beta test today we'll be introducing
more content included in the full game
let's take a look at what you can expect
when EXO Primal Launches on July 14th
let's start with the story Ace the
game's protagonist is transported to the
year 2040 and forced to participate in a
never-ending series of War Games the
story unfolds as you play through Dino
survival the game's main mode Gathering
Intel to update the analysis map
unravels the Mysteries surrounding
parallel worlds and the AI entity known
as Leviathan at times players will also
engage in special boss battles as part
of the main story
Dino survival mode will also change as
the story progresses
you'll unlock new missions with a
variety of objectives including 10
player co-op a multitude of dinosaurs to
fight and more maps
the game will also feature an assortment
of unlockables and challenges
modules can be used to enhance exosuits
and modify active skills
these modules can be obtained by
fulfilling certain conditions while you
play the game
you can also personalize your appearance
with a variety of Cosmetics such as
exosuit skins weapon skins decals and
emotes
the game also features a special
five-player mission that changes weekly
compete with squads from around the
world for the fastest completion times
or by earning Awards through
achievements like most damage block with
a tank suit in Battle
there are many ways to enjoy the game
even after completing the main story
we took your feedback into consideration
as well in the full version of EXO
Primal we plan to implement a mode where
Victory is determined by completing
missions as quickly as possible instead
of direct combat with other players we
hope you look forward to that
now let's go over all the new info we
just saw in the video
who was that new face at the beginning
meet Dr signs the developer of the EXO
suits
and the head of anchor division ibs's
Elite research group based on bikitoa
Island
strativator a space elevator that
extends from the anchor division
research facility into orbit will also
be a playable map
credible battles will unfold while EXO
Fighters and dinosaurs Clash atop this
massive space elevator
players will even encounter dangerous
mutations of dinosaurs known as
neosource the most deadly among them
being the Neo T-Rex
you'll need to work together with your
team to stand a chance at taking them
down
oh no is that a swarm of Neo T-rex's
water leviathan's true intentions
wait what's the deal with this new exo
suit
while it may look similar to Deadeye
this exosuit is a variant called Deadeye
Alpha burst fire
unlike the default Deadeye this variant
comes equipped with a weapon that can
burst fire or be used as a shotgun
allowing exo-fighters to change their
style of play
exosuit variants including Deadeye Alpha
will be added in a title update
following the full version's release
at the end of the video we revealed
Savage gauntlets a mode that lets you
take on special five-player missions
that change weekly
in this mode players can enjoy a change
of pace from Dino Survival by competing
against EXO fighters from all over the
world for the fastest completion times
more info about exosuit variants and
Savage Gauntlet will be revealed that
the Xbox games showcase extended
be sure to tune in
and last but not least
we're excited to announce that we'll be
holding a second open beta test
this time we're including additional
Story related missions
10 player co-op missions
and other adjustments based on
everyone's feedback
check out the official website for dates
and times
we hope you're all excited to try out
this new content
players will also receive a new reward
for participating don't miss out
we'll continue to make adjustments to
exoprimal leading up to the game's
launched on July 14th
thank you again for all the feedback
we look forward to seeing you in the
second open beta test
that's all we have for you today
see you in the war games it's going to
be a ton of fun